la mobilité européenne une action
visible par les jeunes yvelinois c'est
la mission du bureau d'information
jeunesse à montigny le bretonneux
ce centre départemental d'information
auprès des jeunes est labellisé euros
desk un point d'entrée destiné aux
jeunes pour des projets erasmus plus ou
de volontariat financé par l'union
européenne il ya quand même des fonds
qui sont dédiés à la mobilité des jeunes
et qui sont pas forcément toujours très
connue de ces jeunes erasmus plus c'est
un
indice positif donc là ça vient de
redémarrer 2021 et 2027 il ya des
beaucoup d'argent qui est dédié
justement le coup de pouce pour que les
jeunes puissent partir comme je vous
disais qu'ils soient stagiaires
étudiants jeunes travailleurs demandeurs
d'emploi ou même volontaire pour pour
pouvoir avoir une expérience à
l'étranger autre exemple de présence
d'actions européennes dans les yvelines
destiné à un public ciblé la politique
d'insertion du département un ensemble
d'actions porté par l' agence activités
en collaboration avec différents acteurs
de l'emploi sur le territoire des
mesures financées en partie par le fonds
social européen
c'est des cycles d'appel à projet de
trois ans sur deux cycles d'appels à
projets et sur deux grandes missions ses
4 millions d'euros
qui de fonds sociaux européens qui ont
été captées pour à la fois payés les
finances et les personnels qui sont à
l'accompagnement de ces publics qui sont
en recherche d'insertion mais c'est
aussi pour le département la
sécurisation de toutes les associations
qui font des demandes de fonds sociaux
européens est dense dans cette même
politique et la politique d'insertion
entre 2014 et 2020 le département des
yvelines a piloté une enveloppe de 16
millions d'euros en provenance du fonds
social européen